[Music]
we say good morning good morning to
grant hill seven-time nba all-star works
for turner's sports covering the nba and
the ncaa two-time ncaa champ at duke
grant how are you today bud
hey dan i'm doing well how about you i'm
doing great the story you'll tell about
mike schuszewski to your grandkids
is what
he had a difficult last name to spell
that's it
no
uh forgive me it took me until my junior
year to learn how to spell it no i'm
just just uh
you know just an incredible coach
obviously one of the great coaches in uh
but is there one a story where you got
yelled at or that that he started crying
or
something that stands out
you don't want to say to your grandkids
he was a great coach you go hey you will
not believe this here's the story
yeah i mean look i got yelled at
frequently particularly early on um you
know during my time you know i think
coach k set the tone for me in my four
years there duke
in our very first meeting my freshman
year first day of school first time
the entire team
assembles together
and he established the vision for that
team in that year
by putting the national champions on the
board in the locker room and i'm
thinking to myself i'm looking around
the locker room i'm like like this
team's not good enough to beat unlv
that's the first thing going through my
mind i mean the team had lost three
three seniors from a championship or
from a from a team the year before you
had a young roster vegas was so dominant
in the finals against duke the year
before returned to everybody
but coach k said it in a way
that by the end of that conversation i
believe and i think all of us in that
locker room believe that we didn't
believe we were championship material at
that moment but if we
followed his plan if we bought in
if we played for one another you know if
we embodied what duke basketball is all
about uh that was all said and done we'd
have a chance to to be champions and we
were and so his ability to sell his
ability to get you to buy in
is really his genius dan
and it's a farewell tour uh
it's going to be strange i don't know
how it's going to be for you you know
you tune in and watch duke basketball
and you know you're watching coach k but
uh john shire taking over and
uh
it'll be interesting
interesting to see
it'll be very interesting uh you know
obviously a lot of fanfare farewell tour
i mean everywhere he goes it'll be the
last time last time in charlottesville
last time at clemson last time
uh you know going to to carolina and
what's crazy is
i would imagine some of these schools
might even celebrate him or honor him in
some form of fast can you imagine him
getting honored in chapel hill oh
they're absolutely going to honor it
they're going to be glad he's gone
right you might be right about that you
might be right even in carolina probably
so we spent a lot of time talking about
the steelers game with the bears last
night and yeah i know you got a football
background with your father but it's
just these run-ins you have with
officials like how many times would you
feel like something was
personal with an official or he was
trying to get you or didn't like you
how often would that happen
you know
it didn't happen much i mean you know
you go back in the 90s in the nba
you know the officials you could talk to
them you know you could you could have a
discussion with them you know there was
a respect they commanded uh yeah they
you know you didn't always see eye to
eye sometimes you got technicals but um
you know
i think we've moved away from that in
some respects in all sports not just in
the nba but in nfl and uh in various
sports and i think because of the tv
coverage and uh the banter back and
forth the interactions they've tried to
limit that uh and i think sometimes you
know players need to be able to discuss
things with with officials and in the
moment the heat of the battle uh we've
changed the rules significantly
but back in the day yeah look i mean you
know there were times where you know i i
messed up i i was wrong i shouldn't have
yelled at you i i've even been tossed
i'm not proud of that
uh back in the day but you know it
certainly seems like we've changed and
we we don't permit the interaction
between players and officials and the
rules sometimes can be very very rigid
and certainly that was you know on
display last night in that football game
which was very controversial down the
stretch i wonder how your career would
have turned out
if you were going to duke now and you
were a one and done because you probably
would have been a one and done coach k
would have said you know what are you
doing get out of here
how do you think your career would have
been if you'd gone in as a freshman
instead of after your senior year
it's a great question um you know i i
don't think i would have been as
connected to duke and maybe just you
know you know college basketball
uh like you know like i am now i think
you know the four years that we played
in the early 90s whether you liked duke
or you despised duke you know you saw
duke and people i think recall and
remember those and still 25 30 years
later there's still documentaries and
books and and still you know still in
people's you know uh memories of those
teams in those years and it's hard to
sort of capture that just in one year i
think for some of these guys now i think
with the new name image and likeness i
would have relied less on janet and
calvin
as a freshman uh that's for sure i would
have you know instead of uh stretching
twenty dollars for two weeks i i would
have uh
possibly had more to deal with what do
you think you would have made name image
and likeness
your freshman year
oh man you know i i think
the player i was as a freshman in
today's environment with duke and the
hype and the social media
i say at a minimum and i'm going to be
real conservative i'd say six figures
okay yeah and what would later have
gotten
oh yeah later look let me tell you
something later was so big
i mean it was like i was the bass player
for you know for
you know a pop star i mean leightoner
was larger than life lightner was
one of people magazine's
50 most beautiful
people
his senior year
uh i mean you you you know i mean come
on now the trash talking both ways with
that was was unreal but layton was
larger than life was was certainly a
celebrity on campus
uh everyone loved him uh sometimes we
hated him but uh he was certainly uh a
star and he would have yeah seven
figures maybe eight figures
[Laughter]
i mean dad dad he had stephen king like
stephen king which is kind of odd but
stephen king would come down to durham
and hang out with christian layton wait
so the writer stephen king
yes would hang out with later
i mean one day i remember going over to
his apartment on off day and i and like
stephen king is in his like in his
living room you know and this is like
early his senior year
and so i mean like what like that
doesn't happen you know and uh didn't
happen much back then and doesn't happen
now but but you know he was um you know
quite a player delivered when it
mattered most and certainly was was big
time back in the day would have made a
lot of money maybe stephen king was
getting inspiration for somebody a bad
guy in his book like let me get somebody
who's really feared and hated hey
christian can i come down and talk to
you for a little while
you know all right
no comment no comment
he's grant hill joining us uh seven-time
nba all-star two-time ncaa champion duke
how would you cover
steph
curry wow uh you know sometimes
the best defense is good offense and uh
i i think you know wear him out on the
other end try to pick up two fouls
uh but you know
how he has played this year you know
after you know being hurt two years ago
coming back having a fantastic season
and now
uh his play mvp discussion
what he did last night to my atlanta
hawks i mean just
it was legendary and uh painful as a
hawk uh fan and owner to watch but just
beautiful in terms of his game
back to that 2015-2016
forum
that we saw you know i thought he really
took uh really sacrificed his game uh
for kevin durant and rightfully so kevin
durant great player
new environment i think steph curry
people don't appreciate how he went out
of his way i believe to make durant feel
comfortable and and then he got hurt
once durant left
but he's back to that sort of pre-durant
2015 form and you know golden state
fun and exciting to watch and look we
all were saying in the preseason if they
can just hold it together in the western
conference until clay comes back
wow this team would be scary but you
know what this is scary right now you
know and it it's it's it's you know it's
unimaginable to think what they'll be
once they get klay thompson back to form
but you know when you see and jj redick
was as pure a college shooter as i've
ever seen he was a
wonderful you know he made shots and the
net didn't move
but
is anybody compared to steph curry
that you remember that as far as that
good a shooter
you know i had the good fortune of
playing with steve nash in phoenix and
at the time i thought steve nash was the
best
shooting point guard in the history of
the nba
historically was a 50 it was a 50 40 90
guy 50 from the field 40 from the
three-point line 90
from the free-throw line
uh i i i at the time we had not seen a
point guard who shot the ball as well as
steve now he was also a great passer and
was at times a reluctant shooter
but steph has just taken it to a whole
nother level with his shooting with his
range uh with the volume of shots that
he takes
really has you know changed the game you
know it's been a transformational guy i
think of you know you think of
you know got luau fender way back in the
day and how he changed the game and
widened the lane outlawed the dunk you
think of michael jordan uh during his
heyday
influence and how he changed the game
also off the court culturally
but then steph curry just like
kind of goofy silly looking you know
looks like a kid out there uh has become
the most dangerous player in the nba but
also has really transformed and embraed
and uh ushered in this new era of
shooting from long range but
no one can replicate or duplicate what
he's done and i'm not sure we'll see a
guy like him for for quite some time how
concerned would you be if you're a laker
fan right now lebron's out for a month
the abdominal strain russell westbrook
doesn't seem like the right fit there
it's early but is this going to be the
same pattern that we see even when
lebron comes back
you know i i called that game last night
the lakers played against charlotte and
um you know
they they escaped with the win the
lakers there in overtime and it
shouldn't have come to that uh this team
is still trying to figure itself out as
you said
um you know at times it looks a little
disjointed you know the pieces you
question do they all fit now in fairness
you have to get lebron back and trevor
ariza and taylor horton tucker and
an assortment of kendrick nunn
so it's hard to fully evaluate this team
in this roster uh right now but you know
one the abdominal strain is something
that lebron has to be very very careful
with that's something that can linger
for an entire season if you're not you
know not smart about how you treat it uh
but this team you know
it's just it's it's a big question mark
you know and the expectation in la the
expectation with any lebron james team
is to win a championship but i'm not in
love with this roster you know i'm not
in love with the pieces
uh and how they fit we still have time
to figure it out i will say though i'll
give credit and i got to give credit to
him and how he played last night and how
he's been all season the one consistent
theme has been carmelo yeah carmelo
anthony has really embraced this off the
bench six-man role
uh really shooting the ball efficiently
from the field had i think 29 points
last night six three pointers made so
he's been the one sort of uh shining you
know bright spot for the team here but
i i'm not sure i really you know you
know the role players the wing guys the
shooters
you know the the ingredients necessary i
think to have success with lebron
i'm not a big big fan of this roster and
in the western conference
you know you get behind too far it's a
lot to make up for they don't want to be
in the spot they were in last year
playing in the play on playing games but
they very well could find themselves
right back there at the end of the
season i know you're taking part in a
new initiative uh start strong tell the
audience what that's about
yeah no thank you dan and uh you know
i've partnered with uh dendrion
pharmaceuticals uh to have a start
strong campaign for uh prostate cancer
patients and so you know it's
interesting prostate cancer uh you know
hits all men but disproportionately
impacts african-american men
african-american men are twice as likely
to be diagnosed and two and a half times
more likely to die
from prostate cancer so raising the
awareness
getting people of color in the
african-american community uh to go to
get checked to get screened uh if you
find it early it can be treated and and
and cure and you can have a you know go
on with a successful life
but typically in our community in the
african-american community we don't like
to go to the doctor we don't like to go
uh and get checked and oftentimes uh we
find out and it's too late so this start
strong campaign is really just about
game planning you know preparing as you
would as a team in the nba or the nfl
with your health taking ownership as you
know dan i've had loads of injury issues
throughout my career but i understand
the importance of taking ownership
taking control
and together with dendrion
pharmaceuticals we're encouraging all
men but particularly african-american
men
to do the same so you can go to a great
website so much information at
strong www.startstrong.com u s
and i just appreciate dan you give me an
opportunity to talk about it always
great to see you buddy thank you for
joining us grant
all right thank you dan that's grant
hill turner sports nba ncaa analyst
seven-time all-star two-time champ at
duke